this Michigan State player might be the
bounciest Hooper in the nation meet
Cohen Carr who's bound to jump out of
the gym on any given night Cohen was a
fourar prospect and ranked in the top 10
among fours in his class but he's
already a Human Highlight re with dunks
like these sheesh listed at 67 he's able
to perform dunks like these on the
regular Cohen is in a special class of
guys who have an insane bounce and this
is the crazy part Cohen hasn't had his
vertical jump measured yet so how can we
tell already that he's in an elite class
this clip shows him almost touching the
top of the back with his head clearly
over the rim that's nearly 13 ft in the
air Michigan State basketball should be
fun to watch this season for sure and
you don't want to miss Coen Carr
performs some of the craziest duns we've
ever seen